round five of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest tour  with a clear leader to chase the best  chess players on the planets came into  the round desperate for a win world  number one Magnus Carlsen built up a  gigantic initiative against us champ  Wesley so but after almost six hours and  68 moves the American star held his  nerve and stopped the champ dead in his  tracks tournament leader Fabiano Caruana  landed in a difficult game against  former world champion Vishwanath on  Anand but after the veteran cracked  under the pressure Fabi completely  turned the tables and extended his lead  over the rest of the field I felt like I  would lose at some point when I saw  Bishop c1 I I suddenly started getting a  bit more optimistic about my chances  after a day of rest the players are  refreshed and ready to fight once again  round six of the season-ending classic  starts right now